تناشد رجال
الإنقاذ المتطوعين بشدة البحث عن زوجها بدير الذي
دفن ، تقول في شقتهم الزاوية
الواقعة في مكان ما تحت هذا
الركام [
الموسيقى]
نحاول مواساتها لكن أم
التوأم هذه تريد العمل وليس الكلمات ،
فلا أحد هناك ، لقد كان هناك ستة
أيام أنا أنتظر هنا مع توأمي
يقفان في البرد ، تقول إنها
تطلب من أي شخص سيستمع لإخراج
زوجها ، لكن لمدة ستة أيام تقول إن
المسؤولين ظلوا يخبرونها أنهم بحاجة إلى
إذن من الحكومة للبدء
في بنائها الذي
أريده  عاد زوجي حتى لو لم يكن على
قيد الحياة ،
فربما تكون قد قبلت وفاته ولكن
لا يمكنها الاستمرار دون رؤية
جثة زوجها تُزال من هذا الجحيم
[موسيقى]
حياتي ، دمي ، كل شيء ، أعز
أصدقائي في الحياة تركني مع توأمي
هنا  بمفردها
بينما تنتظر حقائق
وفاة زوجها هنا في هذه المنطقة حيث
ترى أكوامًا هائلة من الأنقاض ، فهذه
مبانٍ مختلفة ولكن لا يمكنك
حقًا التمييز بينها لأن هناك
الكثير من الدمار كان هناك
علامات على الحياة تم العثور على طفل  هنا على
قيد الحياة بعد أسبوع من تحت الأنقاض ،
ممرضات ، راحة الفتاة التي يعتقدون
أنها تبلغ من العمر ثلاث أو أربع سنوات ، إنها
مصابة بالجفاف وفي حالة صدمة لكنها على قيد الحياة
هذه هي اللحظة التي تم إنقاذ
جسدها الصغير المنهك الذي تم سحبه من
تحت جبال الأنقاض التي لا نهاية لها على ما يبدو
في هاتاي
تم نقلها على وجه السرعة إلى المستشفى المؤقت الذي
أقيم في موقف السيارات
بالمستشفى الفعلي الذي تم إخلاؤه بعد
الزلزال
عندما وصلت لأول مرة كأم
شعرت أنها كانت مثل ابنتي ،
هذه الممرضة تقول
إنها تكسر الموظفين الذين
تتحدث معهم عندما  مشينا في طفل صغير
نجحنا في جعل الممرضات يضحكن
بالارتياح لأنها يمكن أن تتحدث قليلاً ما الذي
قالت إنه جعلكم تضحكون جميعًا ، لقد
جعلت جميع الممرضات تضحك
ماما الكلمة التي جعلت جميع الممرضات
تضحك كانت ماما وأنا  جائع ، أريد أن
آكل شيئًا
ما فعله ذلك بقلبك عندما
قالت ماما لقد
شعرت بنبض عظيم في قلبي ،
قالت إنه
لا أحد يعرف اسمها وعندما سألوها قالت
دادا ، اتضح أن هذا الطفل الصغير
لا يتحدث التركية.
أخبرنا رجال الإنقاذ العرب لاحقًا أنها سورية ، لقد
علمنا الآن بعد ثمانية أيام من وقوع
الزلزال الأول وانهيار
المبنى أن المرأة التي رأيتها هناك
كانت تنتظر زوجها
يتوسل ليجده جيدًا ،
وقد تم العثور عليه ميتًا و  الآن
عليها أن تدفنه